hello there today we'll look at deep
symbolic regression for recurrent
sequences by stefan dascoli pierre
alexandre camini guillaume lump and
francois
this is another paper where the main
part will be an interview with the first
author stefan and i'll just briefly
introduce the paper right here for
10-ish minutes or so so if you want to
just skip to the interview feel free
we'll go over the paper just so that you
know what's going on and there is also
an interactive demo online where you can
try it out and it's a good place to
start at what this paper is trying to do
so in this paper the authors care about
symbolic regression to number sequences
they have a model for integer and float
number sequences in this case this is an
example for an integer sequence so you
can enter any sequence right here
you can see that the sequence that is
already entered is the fibonacci
sequence and you enter as many terms as
you want obviously the more you enter
the more success probability the model
is going to have um and what the model
will do down here is it will predict an
expression you can see it correctly
predicts the expression for the
fibonacci sequence saying that the
current element is the last plus the
last last element and it will predict
the next terms for you and it will
extrapolate the sequence that you've
input so you can
do any
any that you want so i'm going to go
one
i'm very bad at coming up with stuff on
the spot two
one three
one four
one five
let's see if it can get that so as soon
as you exit from
the model
it will
yeah look at that so the quotient which
is
not even sure what that operation is but
ah so it divides it divides the sum of
the last elements maybe
by the last element
it figured it out somehow it is it is
not really good at like if conditions
and this is one thing we're going to
talk about in the interview but you can
see it correctly predicts the next
sequence right here so give that a try
this is this pinpoints exactly what this
paper does it does symbolic regression
for recurrent sequences recurrent
sequences are sequences of numbers that
can be somehow expressed as a logical
rule as a function of the last elements
of the sequence there is like most
sequences can be expressed like this for
example they give a bunch of examples
right here one two
one two four seven eleven sixteen so you
can see that it's always sort of plus
one plus two plus three plus four plus
five and so on or this function right
here these are simply the squares so the
recurrence relation actually isn't a
recurrence relation at all but it is
also a special case of a recurrence
relation or this formula right here it
can get very complicated they have a
bunch of examples right here of
recurrence relations as you can see they
can go pretty complicated uh to express
something like the final digit of n
times n plus one divided by two or the
final do two digits of two to the n or
some maximum or anything like this
so the goal of the model is that you
input a sequence like this and then the
model will output this recurrence
relation it will not output the numbers
directly of the sequence of the
following numbers that's what they would
call a numeric model and they also train
one as a baseline but the model would
actually output exactly the formula
itself and then you can use the formula
to produce the next elements now the
good thing is we've all seen what
happens if you train a numeric model on
like a bunch of data points let's say
these are your input data points you
train a numeric model on that it will
perform pretty well on the data you give
it but as soon as you go like outside of
that data as soon as you extrapolate too
much away from the support base of the
training data without very strong
inductive biases it will sort of
do whatever you can't really predict it
what it will do where there is no
training data that's why also deep
learning relies on on lots of training
data in covering a lot of the input
space whether that's called extra or
interpolation or whatnot we'll we'll
leave it at that but if you have a
symbolic regression and the symbolic
regression actually predicts the correct
formula to match this sequence right
here like think oh this is just a sine
wave then you can extrapolate
indefinitely right and
because you have the correct symbolic
formula you'll be right you know uh in
all places so potentially this is a very
very strong method for certain types of
problems this paper considers this a
sequence to sequence problem so it
considers transformer stacks and this is
i guess along the classic transformer
stack of you have an encoder and a
decoder stack the encoder stack gets fed
with the input sequence as numbers so
here one one two
three five and so on that is the input
sequence it is fixed and then the output
sequence is the formula that you want to
predict and they predict the formula in
reverse polish notation
of the prefix tree of the formula so
they have an example down here
for example the cosine of 3x can be
expressed as this as cosine of
multiplying 3 by x
so you would you would sort of load it
onto the stack and then work your way
down the stack in
in this reverse reverse polish notation
measure so that would be cosine of mole
of 3
of x or whatever that formula is and
then you try to train your transformer
to auto aggressively predict first the
first token without seeing those tokens
and then once you have the first token
you want to predict the second token
given the input and the first token
there is like there's multi-head
attention in here like
uh there is cross attention over here
there's
self attention in here as well your
regular transformer stack so this is
classic sequence to sequence problem the
only question is how do you obviously
encode the input and the output the
output we've already discussed and they
have a very detailed description of how
they produce the data so what they do is
they take a bunch of operators you can
see them in this table and they make
random formulas from those operators
they have a bunch of constraints on
these formulas but essentially they make
random
a data set out of just random formulas
so first of all they sample the number
of operators between one and a maximum
number in this case that would be 10. 10
is the maximum number of operators and
then they build a unary binary tree with
that many nodes so they for example they
would sample two operators right here
like there or three a relu a sub and a a
mod
and then they would build a unary binary
tree so
relu
then that is a unary thing right so it
only has one input so sub that's a
binary operation so it needs two inputs
um here let's say mod that again needs
two inputs
so the second step is to sample the
nodes of the tree from the list of
operators okay that's what we've already
done we've combined steps one and two
sample the recurrence degree between 1
and dmax dmax is 6. so we're maximum
allowed to look back six elements into
the past this is kind of a markov
condition you can say your recurrence
relation can only look back six items
that's kind of a limit
but most sequences that humans could
come up with don't refer back to the
seventh last element right there is
usually a way to express it in forms of
either the current index or their last
few like three or four elements at max
then they sample the leaves of the tree
so the leaves of the tree are either a
constant with probability p constant
these all these probabilities are
one-third and they stress very much that
hyper parameter settings are not very
crucial in this way they sample the
leaves of the tree so either it is a
constant or the current index or one of
the previous terms of the sequence
so let's do that so we'll say here we
sample the previous term which is u n
minus two here we sample the index which
is n and here we sample a constant which
is three so that would result in the
formula relu
of
u n minus 2
minus and then n mod 3.
that would be the formula for this then
they need to sample initial terms of the
sequence so in with the formula you also
need to decide you know how the initial
terms the initial terms since we go back
two elements we need probably at least
two elements at the beginning of the
sequence so let's call that one and two
that's we also need to sample that from
a distribution you can see here that's
just a uniform distribution from
negative 10 to 10.
and then what's the last
sample the sequence length and compute
the next l terms so now we say okay how
much leeway do we want to give the model
to infer the sequence let's say we want
to give it five elements and now we use
the formula to calculate the next three
terms right here all right i tried it it
didn't work out but it is a rather
complicated sequence i have to say but
now you see how this stuff is sampled so
um you see how the formulas are made
they just define a maximum depth of
maximum length and so on and then they
just sample random data from that they
create a data set the data set would be
this one right here this would be the
input and the output to predict would be
the formula in reverse polish notation
it's a sequence to sequence task and
that's it now during inference they can
do a beam search they can input again
the sequence they can output different
formulas different
they can start out different formulas
and then they can do a beam search and
check which of the formulas actually
match
the input sequence that they have
already and they can discard or rank
down formulas that don't match the input
sequence on the first few terms so that
is an additional benefit they have from
this symbolic regression ultimately they
will end up with a formula that probably
fits the input terms and hopefully is
simple enough and the simplicity comes
from the data set since shorter
sequences are more likely to be sampled
in longer sequences the model is
implicitly biased towards easier
formulas which kind of plays into ocam's
razor so that's it that's the method
they create a data set massive data set
they train on random formulas train
train to predict them from the initial
terms and then they evaluate it as i
said they also have float
sequences but
i won't go into that too much notably
they do
outperform this numeric model the
numeric model simply tries to learn the
number two number sequence just directly
without going to the symbolics so as you
can see the symbolic method is better
when evaluating on in distribution
sequences when evaluating on out of
distribution sequences
and here's a question of how do you even
do that there is this database of
integer sequences and after a bunch of
filtering you end up with a validation
set of 10 000 sequences this validation
set are human made number sequences like
the fibonacci sequence or anything
essentially that you where humans can
come up with some sort of logic of how
the sequence is generated
on this data set they don't perform as
well as the numeric model as you can see
right here so the numeric model
outperforms the symbolic model but there
are good reasons why that might be
and we also discussed this in the
interview lastly they also make do
experiments with robustness to noise
which are also very interesting in that
they can even uh suffer from a bit of
noise if they train
with the noise and so the model is even
a bit robust they can still do symbolic
inference which classically if you have
a symbolic system these are usually not
that robust to noise because it's it's
more like hit or miss but if you train
appropriately you can handle that
also interesting is that they encode the
numbers not as continuous values in the
transformer but actually as tokens so at
least for the first 10 000 numbers they
are all their own tokens so the number
19 and the number 20 they're just two
tokens but it turns out that if you
train the model then in the embedding
space the tokens will actually form a
sort of continuous not necessarily line
but a continuous manifold in the
embedding space which is really cool to
see that the model even though you give
the numbers as different tokens it
learns to map them out according to
their numerical values they also have
investigations into the similarities
between embeddings and they uncover some
interesting structures where
similarities are also according to the
numbers like common denominators and so
on and they give a bit of evidence that
there seems to be kind of a natural base
for mathematical operations of multiples
of 6 and 12 and they say that you know 6
is a natural base for reasoning
reminiscent of much earlier explanation
by other people and you might you might
know the this cult of people i don't
even know what they they're called but
this cult of people that says we should
just switch to base 12 because it makes
everything easier so there might
actually be
you know stuff behind that or it might
just be a artifact of how we do math who
knows they experiment a bunch of stuff
with expression simplification and so on
but the model seems to be quite robust
to any of these modifications i think
this is really interesting work in that
symbolic inference i believe can lead us
forward and tackle problems of of
extrapolation that we aren't necessarily
going to be doing with these numeric
models that we currently have obviously
this has its own limitations and its own
biases built in uh most notably how you
construct the data set is very very
crucial to how the model is then going
to perform but it is interesting to see
that you can train it like this and
essentially it's a
you know it's a it's a free free
training data because you can just
generate it by yourself
so without further ado i want to jump
directly into the interview because we
go over the important aspects of the
paper again let me know if you like
inter like interview content like this i
think it is super duper helpful and the
interview was very fun i hope you find
that as well all right see ya
welcome everyone uh today i have with me
right here stefan duskoli who is the
first author of the paper deep symbolic
regression for recurrent sequences
stefan welcome thank you very much for
being here yeah pleasure bad timing to
have covered but i'll try my best to
yeah
i hope this goes i hope this goes over
uh relatively smoothly for you
um
but yeah
so this paper i have to say it gathered
quite some hype online right and uh
because symbolic mathematics is
something that is still
still even though computers are very
good at math per se at numerix symbolics
is something that
has been maybe in the human domain a
little bit more especially this kind of
sequence guessing right it seems to be a
very very human thing something you
would do maybe in high school to try to
like figure out some sequence and figure
out the rules behind it uh what
what
sort of what prompted you to go into
this direction in the first place like
why do you why do you think this is a
fruitful direction or you know what made
you come up with an idea i know there's
some previous work uh but
you know why this
yeah so as you say i mean uh this kind
of problem is very common like iq tests
so that was definitely one of the
motivations so originally this project
was born from uh francois and guillaume
who have been both working on on papers
for so basically deep learning for
symbolic math uh for a couple years and
um what they've been exploring is
several directions the first one of them
was a paper in 2019 called deep learning
for symbolic regression where they
basically did symbolic to symbolic
manipulations basically just integrating
functions solving odes and stuff and
then more recently francois has been
working on a numeric numeric task
involving math which is basically doing
linear algebra so
taking a matrix and then outputting its
inverse or stuff like that
and so a natural continuation of this
was to start from numeric data and go to
a symbolic formula and that's basically
a symbolic regression which means you
take a function uh you only see its
values and you have to try and infer the
expression of the function
and uh indeed it's kind of surprising
that the this has been studied quite a
lot for
quite quite a few decades actually this
this
this symbolic issue this symbolic
regression question um especially with
like genetic algorithms and stuff like
that but there hasn't yet been in the
machine learning literature paper
working on sequences and as you said
it's a very common uh setup for us
humans and so this is originally the
motivation
and so francois came to discuss with uh
me and pierre
alexander alexander is more from the
reinforcement learning background which
is also relevant to sequences because
you have basically a sequence of states
and for me it's because i came from the
physics background and this is also
symbolic regression is useful also for
physics for like inferior laws etc so
yeah that's kind of how we got together
cool excellent and just so we're we're
clear to anyone the kind of sequences we
talk about we have a bunch of examples
uh right here so
that would be
for example here the final
the final digit of n times n plus one
divided by two that's kind of the
formula of all possible pairwise
connections in a group of of n points um
or is that n times n minus one
yeah
the sum of integers okay
um
okay and and from that we just want the
final digit so this the sequence here is
zero one three six zero five one eight
six five that is it is it is i would i
would call it pretty complicated if you
just gave me this as a human but there
is some kind of a rule behind it right
that i can figure out and that's the
type of sequences you would you would
consider this one is actually a good
example it's kind of hard to recognize
for us and if you look at the formula
that the model gave us
you can actually figure out why uh it
predicted that formula it's u n minus 1
plus n
and the reason for that is that n n plus
1 divided by 2 is the formula for the
sum of integers and so the way it built
this formula is just to take previous
turn add n and then take the modulus
respect to 10 because that gives you the
final digit so it's kind of a clever
thing that you know would be kind of um
hard to figure out for us yeah so
if you if you could um maybe give the
the pitch of your model itself like the
pitch of your paper itself um just
before we we get into more of the
details it's always super interesting to
hear from the people themselves
describing something like
a brief pitch of what you did here
uh
yeah so i think our starting point was
uh less ambitious
than what it came to so we originally
just started off from the
uh this sort of thing that um
that is quite popular from math lovers
which is the oeis database so the online
encyclopedia of integer sequences where
you have all sorts of sequences you can
play around with them you can try and
guess the next is quite fun to play
around with and um the idea was to try
and build a model which could complete
the sequences so sort of understand the
logic behind these sequences
so originally we only started off with
integer models so we only wanted to
predict integer sequences
and um and we actually realized that
that was pretty easy uh pretty quickly
we managed to get a model working on
integer sequences
and uh so we then started to think about
can we do the same thing for float
sequences which are a bit more
challenging because you have more
freedom in the expressions you can build
you have more operators you have um you
know cosines and exponentials that come
in and and so this is how we sort of i'd
say it was a lot of serendipity really
in the in this work we started off with
this integer sequence problem and then
we figured out things as we were going
on uh so as you can see on the two
tables you have there
the uh constant approximation thing
which we may discuss a bit later was one
of the fun side effects of of trying to
guess sequences is that you actually the
model actually learns to do stuff it
wasn't trained for and
so yeah i'd say the goal of the paper
isn't to provide a you know a model
which is useful for real-world data it's
not going to be able to predict you know
uh
stock market or weather forecast etc
it's more of a like proof of concept of
what you can do with transformers in
terms of math
and you specifically restricted yourself
to to recurrent uh sequences and it i
think it's important to point out sort
of what like what kind of inputs does
your model take and what kind of outputs
does your model give right because a
formula like like these they are you
know written down
uh in many ways there's there's
ambiguities and
i i would guess the inputs are these
numbers right here right so a model gets
this as an input and then it's somehow
has to predict the corresponding formula
so this is the training data is also
like this how does it take the input and
in what form does it output stuff
okay so those are like the two two big
questions so maybe we can start with the
the inputs uh so that's actually quite a
tricky question how do you feed in these
these inputs to the model because um
you know typically deep learning models
uh
don't
don't take like if you think of a
sequence which is like an exponential
you're going to have very huge numbers
uh if the exponential has a positive
sign and very small numbers if the
exponential has a negative sign and so
if you just feed these kind of values
into a deep learning model it's not
going to learn much especially that here
we're dealing with a transformer because
essentially what we want to output is a
mathematical formula which is just like
basically a language and so this is why
we use transformers and so transformers
need to take in embeddings and so we
need somehow to represent our input
numbers as embeddings and that's
complicated because of course integers
just like reals are an infinite set so
you have to sometime somehow find them
find a way to encode them as a fixed
vocabulary and so this is where we
really have to distinguish our two
setups we basically have two different
transformers one for integer sequences
and one for float sequences
so the integer model what it does is
basically it writes numbers in a base b
representation
uh so for example for the number like
yeah exactly like here 325 you could
imagine writing it as three to five in
which case you only need ten tokens
which are numbers
actually it turns out that it's better
to use a long um a larger base
because if you do use a larger baseball
you're gonna have a bigger vocabulary
but you're gonna have shorter sequences
and typically you know transformers have
quadratic complexity they struggle a bit
with very long sequences
uh which is why yeah we we prefer to use
a large base here we use ten thousand as
our base yeah so this is this would be
base 30 and obviously in base 10 000 i
think it's important to note that every
single number from zero to
9999 is its own token right the model
has no inherent
knowledge of you know three comes after
two and four comes after three and so on
all of this has to be
learned it seems exactly it it seems so
weird to say you know uh it is better
to make the model learn essentially
the entire ordering of 10 000 numbers
rather than you know providing that as
some sort of a just to make the sequence
a bit shorter right yeah it's funny did
you ever think of going with continuous
values right because the first my first
intuition would be that i feed the
actual number right and then it's it's
implicit like it's it's in the number
that two is larger than one and three is
larger than two exactly yes so that's
what's really interesting is that that
is one approach and actually we had a
couple discussions on this like how can
we feed in our inductive bias on numbers
directly into the model and well i mean
the problem with this is that here we're
dealing with like
just
one dimensional vectors in some sense
transformers need you know
high dimensional vectors as inputs
and it's not obvious how you represent
these numbers in in a high dimension um
you know because the as i was saying
just before the problem is that these
numbers have very vastly different
scales and you know deep learning models
usually take normalized inputs
and so it's not obvious how you would so
what you want to do is basically map
these numbers you have onto a sphere
and it's not obvious how you would
encode you would put these numbers on
the sphere and so one very simple way is
just to put them randomly on the sphere
and let the model uh decide all by
itself how to put them in the sphere
and this is what we do and what's
interesting is that when you add plot
after training what the embeddings look
like you can see that it has learned in
some sense our inductive bias of um of
putting the numbers in order etc so
these are these are t-sne t-sne plots
right here the left would be the
the um integer embeddings
and it sort of forms this
this this string what do you make of the
t-snape plot here do you think these
things are actually you know uniformly
on a sphere or does the model just use
like a tiny part of the sphere where it
can make sort of a continuous path
well what's for sure is that the uh it's
definitely a low dimensional
representation because you can see that
the ts knee is actually very uh
really shows a smooth pattern usually
when you block tsnes of like word
embeddings in nlp it's going to be a bit
messy like you're going to get clusters
but it's not going to be as well
organized as here so clearly
the
the embeddings are lying somehow in a
low dimensional manifold
and so then you could think okay so why
do we need like 512 dimensions if it's
only using a small amount of them but
that's actually because you know the
transformer is going to eventually use
these these extra dimensions to perform
its calculations really so it's not as
if they're wasted they're actually going
to be used by the model yeah
and the float embeddings are are very
similar right in that you encode them as
like a
a a a sign a mantissa and an exponent
and again
the mantissa if i understand correctly
same deal that you have a token per
number between zero and and ten
thousands and the and the exponent
um
is that correct that
you have you say you have exponent from
negative 100 to 100. so one token would
be
e minus 100 and then another token would
be e minus 99 e minus 98. so these are
all different tokens so now the
transformer has to learn kind of
a two to two different
um
two different embeddings
both are somehow in sequence exactly
yeah
so for the for the so just to summarize
so for the integers uh we encode the
integer as
the sign followed by a token
of the base tokens of the base b
representation of the integer and so for
floats we also have the sine token then
indeed we have the mantissa token so
here the difference is that we only have
one token for the mantis so we don't
have like a base b representation which
means that we do lose some information
in the discretization process and then
indeed to represent the scale of the um
of the number we use uh an exponent
embedding and and that indeed goes
between minus 100 and 100 and so here
indeed we do plot the ts and e of the
exponents because they really have a
logic to them for the mantissa it's it's
less obvious if you plot a tns any of
the mantissas it would look a bit
anarchic but hear the exponents you can
and actually just about this plot here
um
this plot is actually a tiny bit
disappointing because we can't see some
of the really interested features we had
with our first models this is with the
very big big model we with embedding
dimension 512
actually when we were using a smaller
model with a smaller embedding dimension
we saw a really neat pattern um which
was basically the fact that the model
was learning the
arithmetic properties of integers so it
was basically creating a line with two
four six eight ten etc then three six
nine etc and here it's a bit less
obvious probably because the big model
is learning something even more complex
that we can't interpret as easily
if you go in the appendix you do see
actually a figure where we see
uh that the model learns like a basic
representation the attention
um the attention plots you mean uh
actually not those ones
yeah
like if you zoom in the lot on the left
plot you kind of see these these
diagonal lines which are spaced out
every six and every 12
showing that basically the model is
recognizing numbers which have common uh
divisors and
is specializing to the base you know 6
or 12 representation which is often
considered better than the base 10
representation so these plots just to to
make it clear these are the cosine
similarities between each of the tokens
so the tokens would be distributed on
the on the axes here these are tokens
and these are tokens and then we put the
the cosine similarities between every
two tokens so naturally
obviously every token is going to be
very similar to itself but also
very similar to its immediate neighbors
so it seems to really learn this uh
the ordering of all the tokens but then
also yeah what what i found special um
there is this this structure of the the
common sort of the common factors uh
common divisors
between the tokens that's that's really
cool yeah one thing also that's hard to
see in this big model but which was much
clearer in the small model is like you
could see for example the perfect
squares would light would be complete
outliers you you would get like uh 9 16
25 49 which would completely stand apart
due to yeah like sort of special
properties i think that here so here is
49 right that that kind of stands out
right this is this is this this gap yeah
that's something which we haven't really
been able to understand some guy sent me
an email actually saying oh maybe i have
an idea that
there's a gap between 46 and 48 because
uh uh
like 45 has lots of factors of five and
three whereas 48 has lots of twos and
and and
there must be some explanation or maybe
it's just something due to optimization
it's very hard to know okay
yeah i think in this at this point it's
it's a bit um also important that we
look at the data generation process you
you you give the model a bunch of
options right to generate sequences and
these are
where do i have them so here we have the
the operators that it can use on the
left hand side are the integer operators
and then the float operators would be in
addition to the ones on or sorry no
they're they're repeated in part but
also um there are more in the float
formulas and then you just generate in
um reverse polish notation is that
correct exactly so you generate reverse
polish notation formulas given these
these things
and you can also have integer
pre-factors right for for all the things
so either you sample integers or you
sample
you sample
the current
element index
or you sample previous elements of the
sequence so the model could express you
know if it's the fifth element take
phi that current number times the
previous element plus 2 times the cosine
of something either a constant or again
referring to some previous element or
something like this
is is there a logic behind
why you chose
the the why you made these choices of
how you generate these formulas
so actually if you look at this table
indeed there are much more operators for
the real case at the floating point
numbers but you do notice that in terms
of binary operators there are two which
you can see in the integer set up but
you don't see in the float setup which
are integer division and modulus and
this is this really illustrates that
we're trying to learn rather different
things in the two setups really in the
integer setup we're focusing on sort of
arithmetics and arithmetic properties of
numbers whereas in the float setup we're
really interested in a let's say a more
classic uh symbolic regression problem
with with complex operators yeah and
yeah as you said our generation process
is basically to build a mathematical
tree
uh sorry a unary binary tree this is
like previous works by by foswan and
guillaume and then indeed we fill in the
nodes of these trees
either with operators
so the nodes are filled in with
operators
either binary or unary and then the
leaves of the tree indeed as you said
can be either variables or or constants
and as you said uh the the choice of
generators actually basically the front
the the hardest part let's say of this
problem because um one thing that's nice
when you do these kind of uh symbolic
math problems is that you basically have
an infinite data set your data is just
synthetically generated and so you can
train as long as you want you don't have
any sort of um
you know you don't have any overfitting
issues you don't you don't have to
regularize that much you don't have to
even the hyper parameter choices aren't
that important what is really crucial
here is like how you build your formulas
and that's what makes the problem i
think really quite fun to play around
with because it's a bit like you know uh
teaching a kid how to learn maths like
you really have to figure out what is
the best thing to show the model at what
time and
what is gonna you want the day set to be
kind of hard uh so they can deal with
complex cases but if it's too hard it's
gonna learn more slowly i mean it's
really an interesting problem how to
generate the data
and you decided
just by playing around because so you
you do have as we said you you have
these these particular ingredients and i
mean you can always say why didn't you
have more or less and so on but you know
you have a table of a bunch of
operations that you can do
you decided um
as well to make uh to allow the model to
use these sort of recurrence relations
right to allow the model to say uh not
only i want five times n plus two but i
maybe i want five times n plus two times
the
the the previous
or the
the time step two steps back or
something like this uh is there a reason
behind you know including these
recurrence relation is that just
something you thought would be more
interesting or did you look at the
database and see that that's a lot of
how these sequences are made it's true
that often people look at the problem
they want to solve in order to choose
the parameters of their generation for
example
sometimes people use different weights
for how to sample which operators to
sample like they'll put more additions
than multiplication or they'll
here we have for example if you go right
to the left here we have these hyper
parameters for our generator
uh for example you can see here the
probability of choosing a constant leaf
uh or index leaf so n or a previous term
uh well yeah probably we could have like
tuned these parameters somehow but here
we really wanted to have the simplest
choice possible on the rationale that
basically our our data set is so huge
um that is eventually we're going to see
all possible uh formulas at some point
it doesn't matter that much the specific
values we choose and we don't want to
tune them to a specific problem
um and so this is why we really chose
like very standard uh and also for the
operators like we didn't use any
particular probabilities with which to
sample such and such operator we just
left let everything as general as
possible and this would be so this is
built up as a tree because naturally you
can parse uh these things as a tree you
can generate them as a tree to have the
sort of correct grammar but ultimately
you end up with as we said this reverse
polish notation which is a sequence
right it's so this would be this would
be one such formula not you you wouldn't
have x but you would maybe have n or
something like this so but ultimately
this results in a sequence of tokens
right so the input your model is these
numbers encoded in tokens and the output
is
a sequence of these symbolic uh tokens
yeah did you also investigate sort of
the um the embedding space of the output
vocabulary
yes actually a good question so we did
look at that and actually it didn't have
any particular structure you could have
expected maybe like cosine and sine are
going to be close to in the embedding
space um i think what's happening is
that the uh the output space is actually
much smaller right because in the input
space we have a lot of tokens like we
have for integers we have one to ten
thousand that's like ten thousand words
so it really tries to find a structure
in the inputs for the outputs we only
have a very small vocabulary compared to
usual nlp tasks we only have like about
30 operators
and so essentially if you look at the
high dimensional space and you do it
tsne you won't see much because it's
just equally spreading these operators
in the sphere or something like that
there isn't much logic to it here
um and how let's say
um how universal are these sequences
right how how many
sequences that i could come up with
freely would be inside of the scope of
your model and like are there's are
there is there a significant class of
sequences that your
grammar could not express
so um with this unary binary true
representation you can pretty much
represent any function so of course
there are some sequences which don't
have any logic to them which aren't
generated by a recurrence formula in
which case you can't represent these
sequences and that typically is the case
with most of the sequences from the oeis
database there's not an actual so we had
to get rid of quite a lot of them and do
some filtering
now i did say that you can represent any
function but
there is a limitation though is that
some functions are very difficult to
express with this uh tree approach if
you think for example of the collat
sequence uh uh where basically uh for
odd numbers you multiply by three add
one and for
for
even numbers you divide by two that's
the rule which is possible to express
with a mathematical expression
essentially what you do is say is write
it as n modulus two times what you do if
it's uh
even plus yeah one minus one minus that
yeah but that's kind of an involved way
to write it and generally the
model is going to struggle to output
that because it won't have seen it much
during training that's one important
thing also which which we might discuss
a bit more is that it's like a model i'm
sorry sorry is that our model is kind of
biased to the most likely experience the
likelihood of the expression to be
generated during training yeah i wanted
to just it's like a hack right that we
as programmers uh have for an if
condition right it's just something we
learned at some point like oh look you
can you can make an if you have an if
condition you can express it as
like if you i don't know people program
numpy or something like this that's
exactly what you do right you don't say
if you make like your mask with one
minus you know whatever condition and
plot you know and you multiply by this
and then you have
uh you know that and i think anyone who
programs numpy or tensorflow or so on
knows okay i can do it like this and
then my stuff is you know expressible
and differentiable as one formula so and
but i think that's a that's a hack we
learn right and if we just if we just
generate data at random like you do you
this is not something you come across
as often as we come across when we you
know program
exactly yeah yeah it's uh it's very
unlikely to see this formulation in our
and uh in our data sets yeah absolutely
okay cool um but but you know at the end
of the day you generate a giant data set
right there you go you go through it
with transformers and you you make sort
of you emphasize transformers is there
something special about transformers
like
because couldn't can i use any any
deep learning thing or you know why
transformers
well um first of all like previous
experience i mean um guillermo and
francois have been working on these
transformers they've
basically always been good at the
problems we've given them
likely i mean one natural justification
is that as we saw for the outputs you
can represent math as a language in a
very easy way it's actually we can see
here that it's much harder to represent
the inputs as as tokens but the formulas
themselves are very easy to represent
as as a language with this polish
notation thing and so it's very natural
to use transformers because they're our
best models to to deal with language
um
so yeah i think that's the
the main reason and um
yeah
i i i'm not sure what else we could
particularly i mean we could use like uh
rnns etc but you know these days
transformers are so powerful i mean
these models we used we didn't even as i
was saying before we didn't have to tune
them much we just basically took the
same architecture that was used in the
paper two years ago uh we didn't even
have to change the learning rate like
it's pretty amazing how easy it is to
train these things
okay
um
yeah so the
the transformers are natural way to deal
with with sequences and from text
learning we we kind of know this but we
always learn sort of on on human text
right and then and that has a particular
structure and i want to think if i look
at these sequences they're almost like
there's so many
symbolic formulas that could possibly
explain these sequences and yeah i can
you say you make you want maybe the
simplest sequence or you you know you
you don't want your your formulas to
blow up that's you even generate only
formulas that are let's say relatively
simple so there's clearly a bias towards
simplicity but i
still there are a lot of
things that explain the same
sequence so i'm i'm thinking more
is it
like if when we as humans do these tasks
um
is it like a property of of humanity and
civilization that we kind of
come up with the same sequences that the
person you know who made the riddle came
up with is it because we kind of think
alike right because of whatever society
or or our environments that shaped us or
is or is there like a property of math
that says that says well if actually if
you look for the simplest sequence it is
kind of defined even though there are
infinite possibilities like
you do you
know a little bit what i mean is it more
like a property of humanity or of
of mathematics i think it's probably two
different things so as far as humans is
concerned indeed we we tend to prefer
simplicity that's like our ocam's razor
principle we like going for the
compressing information and going for
the simplest representation
um in terms of our algorithm here we
didn't put at all this simplicity
inductive bias
from an explicit point of view we didn't
tell the model give us the the simplest
formula actually we could have done so
because we could have for example given
a penalty to like the decoder when it
generates two long sequences for example
but we didn't have to do this at all
because the inductive bias comes from
from the fact that simple formulas are
more likely to be generated by the
generator and that's basically the
rationale behind our model is that it's
always going to
be biased towards the most likely
formula uh corresponding to the sequence
and as we were saying before sometimes
that's not good because for the collat
sequence it's going to struggle to
output the one minus the mask thing
um but in general that's kind of what we
want in iq tests we ask
we ask for the simplest formula to
explain the observations
is there is there i'm thinking of are
there
more
things rather than just you know number
sequences where something like symbolic
regression could could be valuable i for
example i've always thought of
maybe reinforcement learning would be
much powerful much more powerful right
if we didn't only
even if if agents have a world model
what they call a world model they
usually have like uh look almost like a
numeric world model they just forward
predict the the values that are going to
happen there i always thought well if i
had like a symbolic representation of
the world
i could you know be
do much more powerful planning is there
are you thinking of applications like
these when you develop this right beyond
number sequences or is there any
interesting ones that you know come to
your mind
so as i was saying
my co-author it comes from reinforcement
learning and they've already been a few
papers inserting like some symbolic
parts into rl um
loops uh and that's definitely gonna
help indeed as you say i mean if you're
a robot and you're trying to understand
the world then you're gonna be
it's gonna be much easier if you
understand newton's law if you manage to
if you want to for example predict how
objects are going to move it's much
easier once you understand newton's law
then using like a specific vision uh
model to to try and predict that's going
to be much more complicated so indeed i
think symbolic regression is going to be
very useful for rl
uh from my point of view i'm more from
the physics background and that's also
where a domain where symbolic regression
would be very useful because typically i
mean so we have these two approaches
right we have numerical regression and
we have symbolic regression and i think
they're very complementary in the sense
that numerical regression is complex is
very good on complex tasks where you
don't necessarily have a simple
explanation for the for the data and
symbolic regression is great for sort of
inferring uh data where you have a
simple underlying rule typically in
physics like inferring laws from
observation so yeah i think rl and
physics are definitely two
huge domains of application for symbolic
regression
and to to make this a bit a bit clearer
so what i've done is in the appendix you
actually have some success and failure
cases of your model and so i have i have
made a little quiz out of them and
hidden hidden a bunch of them right here
and i just want to draw people's
attention a little bit to
um some of the some of the so on the
left the left three columns are success
cases and the right three columns are
failure cases both of the integer model
right so these are integer
valued sequences
and do do i have this correctly you do
consider it only a success if the
formula is equivalent or do you consider
it already a success if just the
predicted values are the same
um you can have the two criterions the
criteria we choose in the papers we want
the uh the evaluations to be the same
so even if it comes up with like a
different formula it's it's fine as long
as like the the ones you tested on uh
match yeah that's actually one tricky
thing is that indeed you can't really
rely on the formula to check if it was
correct or not due to the degeneracy and
so some papers have circumvented this by
using like an rl loop because
if you try to really uh supervise the
formula then you can't make some you
have to evaluate the formula which is
non-determined non-deterministic and
then you can't like back propagate this
and so some people have used sort of rl
loops to to provide reward signals from
the evaluations uh what we do is
directly supervise the tokens of the
formula and
and that okay maybe we can discuss this
a bit later but that's also interesting
because you know you could think this is
weird because our our model is
supervised to a formula and it's going
to be penalized if it outputs at
training um an equivalent formula yeah
but that turns out to not be too bad and
we tried we tried we tried
expression simplification and it didn't
help at all it doesn't really matter but
yeah this is very interesting what
you're going to come to uh with the uh
success and failure cases yeah so the
the leftmost column here is is pretty
simple these are okay people already
know it's success cases so
nothing too unexpected right here like
it figures out um that for example the
middle formula this might be a bit small
here even for people to read but this is
um n
n times the sine of
uh gamma
and gamma is what exactly uh it's a
euler's constant euler's cons okay so n
times the s the sine of gamma squared so
the entire thing on the right hand side
is a oh sorry is a constant right so
it's essentially n times a constant yeah
uh so the the model what it has to do is
it has to somehow figure out the
expression for the constant
as a formula right because it it can't
it it
it uh it has to yeah it cannot just
predict the number um
and
then it has to realize that i have to
multiply this constant by n
and that's why it's a straight line so
and the other formulas are similar ish
the top one for example is n minus the
cosine of n
and yeah again reminder these are this
is symbolic symbolic regression
um
now the next ones are
weird so here the top one it starts off
very very weird but then it
continues uh in the same path and you
can still you can see sort of okay it's
regular enough that the model could you
know figure it out from the data points
it has by the way the the green
background that's the input right the
blue background that's that's the what
it has to predict
so the next one i find particularly
interesting it is the formula is the tan
of the the tangent of n
plus n
times the last element and this is what
the output looks like so
you know how like
how can the model
from the just the left part figure out
that this is the correct formula and
then
the the end date that just blows my mind
like how does that work maybe the log
scale would help a bit here because uh
there is probably quite a lot of
variability in the in the first terms
and it's just squashed by the last term
which is huge
okay yeah i should have made it for the
log scale
um
that's a good question
yeah what is it what i find really
interesting with these plots so here
you're showing the success plots and on
the right hand side you have the the
failure plots
is that we really see how symbolic
regression is different from numeric
regression like in direct regression you
have this set of points and basically
you're just trying to fit your function
you're trying to bend the function so
that it goes through the through the
input points and so this is typically
going to be very prone to overfitting
right if you if you can't really
understand the process then you're just
going to fit a function which goes
through the points whereas symbolic
regression here isn't biased towards uh
overfitting at all it's just trying to
find a formula and so when it fails on
the right hand side
it not only fails outside the input
points but also on the input points it's
not even able to fit the points you gave
it so this really shows a big difference
we can see this a little bit i think so
on the bottom left there's a there's a
nice case where it it can it already
fails yeah on the inputs like that's the
best formula it can come up with you do
have a beam search in there right these
ones no no
no
tends to pull a bit more towards
overfitting because in beam search you
so the way we rank our beam is that we
evaluate how uh how well the um formula
matches the input points and so in that
sense you're coming a bit closer to like
actually overfitting the input points
but if you use a beam size of one as
using most of our experiments then
essentially yeah you're not at all
biased towards um overfitting
okay
yeah i mean this it seems like here it's
just misjudged the formula on the top
left is an interesting one where it just
it looks like it's done everything
correctly right it looks like so the red
ones are the the outputs that it's
supposed to match and the black one is
the the line the function it produces
what's wrong here is it like off by a
tiny bit yeah so the screen is pixelated
so i can't see very well but sorry but
yeah um essentially we get two kinds of
mistakes we get the mistakes where it's
very close for example it confuses a
like a four with a five and so it's
going to be very close but then you have
catastrophic failures uh
where basically for example to confuse a
cosine with an exponential or something
like that you know that's just one token
error but it's going to give completely
wrong predictions and that's something
that you typically won't get for for
numerical regression you'll always at
least fit your inputs
however there is one thing where
symbolic regression is better than uh
numeric regression is that once it does
find the correct formula then it's going
to get predict you know perfect
precision on all all the
the subsequent numbers you're going to
give it for if you think for example of
um of extrapolating the sequence with a
numerical model you're always at some
point gonna you know uh get wrong
predictions because you're not very good
at generalizing outside yes typical
thing that deep machine learning is good
at interpolating but bad extrapolating
but with symbolic regression once you've
found the correct formula you can
basically extrapolate as far as you want
you you've got the right formula yeah
and and so just saying uh for people who
probably
even people in the video will not be
able to read i can confirm the formulas
of these two things are completely
different like the one is the sign of
something simple and the one that's
predicted is a very very complicated
formula that just happens to
almost fit or or maybe even perfectly
fit uh the input data points right but
then it is just that tiny bit off
and that that gets worse and worse as
the sort of the output progresses okay
yeah so yeah there are a bunch of about
a bunch of other funny ones like this
one again these the scale here is um the
scale here is observed it's like a e the
exponent is 224 and there's just this
one output that it's supposed to match
and
i mean that's just that's just mean to
the model honestly
yeah we do have i mean horrible
expressions like our generator uses up
to 10 operators and so if you look at
expressions here we only chose
expressions with three operators yeah
you can imagine how horrible the
expressions are with with 10 operators
yeah and of course the accuracies are
much lower i mean if you look at the
ablation like our performance at 10
operates is about 10 versus you know 100
when you only have one operator yeah
so i will i will uh i'll
quickly uncover uh the rest of these but
people are i encourage people to
actually go and and look at the the
success and failure cases also for the
floating models i think it's it's really
valuable and you can directly see as you
say you know the differences between
symbolic
uh regression and i mean if you did
numeric regression even if it has like a
pattern like this like a zigzag pattern
or something it would quickly degrade uh
we've all seen sort of sort of numeric
regression although as in your
experiment so maybe we'll come to to
this last so in your experiments there
are
um
cases where the numeric regression is
worse and there are cases where the
numeric regression is actually better
than the symbolic regression would could
you want to maybe comment a little bit
on the experiments specifically like in
distribution out of distribution
so typically in in
distribution our um
our symbolic model performs better than
the direct model because it's it's got
the right inductive bias right really we
we feed in these these sequences which
are generated by a formula and so it's
much better than the numeric model at
extrapolation because once it's got the
correct formula it's going to give
perfectly precise accurate predictions
extrapolated as far as it wants etc
however it is um
slightly less good at out of domain uh
generalization so one thing you see here
uh
in is i can't remember where it is in
the paper but you see that um for
example numeric
regression is better when you have uh
complex pre-factors right because here
the expressions we generate the the
pre-factors we have are built from like
uh integers between 1 and 10 e and pi
yeah and so that's well fitted for the
symbolic model but what happens if you
replace these prefactors by like
prefactors which is sampled from a you
know
a gaussian distribution so these these
two columns right here the difference
between those yeah exactly and so what's
interesting here is that uh in this case
of course the numerical regression
performs better than symbolic because
numeric doesn't care at all about the
fact that you're using these pre-factors
because it doesn't really care
uh it isn't trying to approximate these
complex pre-factors
what's interesting though is that the
symbolic model still isn't that bad
because it's actually able to
approximate pre-factors with its own
vocabulary and you've probably got a
table with a few examples of this
um
and this is actually a purely something
we discovered we weren't expecting this
at all we suddenly like plotted the
predictions of the model and we realized
what it was doing yeah so okay for
example here if you
use the constants
0.3333 and you feed it to our symbolic
model
well of course it can't directly uh
output 0.333 times n because it doesn't
have 0.3 in its vocabulary so it's going
to have to build somehow this this
constant with
its own building blocks and you can see
that it does that pretty uh remarkably
well
uh and this is very surprising it's
basically what happened is that during
training it has seen some expressions
because our expressions aren't
simplified right so so we don't have
something that is going to evaluate the
expression so sometimes it sees a
formula
which has three plus exponential of
minus six
and it will notice what a numerical
value that evaluates to in terms of the
sequence and so it kind of learns to
build any constant with its own
vocabulary and it's important to say
that you don't like other if if i see
this i would first assume that you have
some sort of uh gradient based regressor
in there like that approximates these
constants for you but you don't right
the model actually has learned that uh
to to output these symbolic expressions
for particular
constants yeah that's something i think
which is a bit uh rather novel here is
that we have an end-to-end transformer
usually in symbolic regression you have
a model which predicts a skeleton so an
expression without pre-factors and then
you sort of fill in the pre-factors with
a separate solver here our model does uh
finding the pre-factors all by itself
so that's nice in a sense because it's
like mathematically satisfying and it
also gives us some quite nice
approximations for example here you can
see with 1.64493
it outputs pi squared over six and you
may know that that's the sum of the
inverse of squares and
uh i think euler in his time spent quite
a lot you know he had to actually found
he found this you know numerical value
and he spent some time figuring out that
it was pi squared over six so that could
potentially be useful for mathematicians
um
of course the drawback of it is that
this is a complex process and if you
have a very complex equation with lots
of complex pre-factors then our model is
going to spend a lot of its uh attention
to building these pre-factors and it's
going to make the task more complex and
this is why i think our model isn't
directly applicable to like real world
problems like you know forecasting where
you have very complex prefactors in
front of each term of the equation
is there any any other surprising things
that you learned in the in the
experiments um
i mean maybe unsurprisingly
a model like this is better than
mathematica which i would have expected
because i'm not i'm not a big fan of
mathematica like
stephen wolfram is cool but
i'm not too too much into the way
mathematica does things except for very
very particular applications
well i mean that's okay i mean it isn't
that bad actually i was surprised at how
how good it was i mean it has like these
two built-in functions uh find sequence
function and find new recurrence
and
basically find sequence function is
going to find like non-recurrent formula
it verifies yeah so for example if you
feed it 2 4 8 16 is going to say 2 to
the n
whereas finally linear occurrence is
really for uh when it depends of the
previous terms in a linear fashion and
and these are actually pretty powerful
because a lot of uh sequences are linear
and and mathematical will always
basically get these right
um because actually you can there's a
there's a deterministic rule to find the
the linear occurrence so that's that's
fine
uh find sequence function is very
limited of course and you can see it
gives worse results than oeis
um but still i mean the these functions
aren't miles away from our model um i
think actually both our models and
mathematica models are struggling a bit
with oes they are outside of their
comfort zone um i think mainly because
um so one thing i should say is that
here we're not evaluating on random
sequences from oeis we selected those
which have a label uh which says easy
which means that there is a logic behind
them there is a recurrence relation
however or not necessarily a recurrence
relation but there is the other ones
just just to clarify the other ones you
gave some examples in the paper of the
other ones would be like
the number of bus stops and you know in
successive streets in new york city or
something where you can't possibly know
unless you consult like some outside
knowledge yeah oei does have a lot of
nerdy um
nerdy sequences which are just for the
fun of it basically and um
um
but even in the ones which are labeled
as easy a lot of the sequences don't
have a recurrence relation for example
the the sequence of primes uh the
sequence of divisors of n the sequence
of decimals of pi all these things you
can't really predict and so these kind
of hamper are our models so i don't
think this is like the best way to show
that our
the power of our model our model is
especially powerful on like
the sequences which are built from the
generator which are very complex here in
mathematica uh in in reis they
our models are just only a tiny bit
better than mathematica i wouldn't say
it's the most impressive
result and they are
specifically also worse than numeric
right you can see that the numeric
models they they do outperform here and
that might also be because
one
of the distribution shift and two
if there are
as well some even though they're labeled
easy but actually you might still need
some outside knowledge a numeric model
at least will sometimes come close to
the solution right close enough to to
count as correct yeah exactly yeah on
direct models is generally going to be
better indeed when when there isn't a
simple formula but you can still infer
logic it's yeah yeah sometimes i mean
you you give very i mean if if you've
played a bit with the demo you'll
realize that sometimes you give a very
simple
sequence for us and for some reason the
model won't be able to recognize it
because it uses our kind of logic which
we can't really express simply as a
formula and the numeric model will be
very good at that
so while yeah i'm gonna quickly open the
demo i hope i have it ready somewhere um
and maybe you can tell us like is there
like in in in the course of this
research
was there a moment where it like didn't
work at all or i mean you had some basis
to go by right from the work of let's
say let's say guillaume and and and
francois uh but was there
like what was the biggest problem
that you encountered during this
research
um to be honest the this was
i was surprised at how quickly we were
able to get uh models working in the
first place uh at least on integer
sequences it was pretty quick to get
some results from that point of view as
i was saying before just plugged in our
transformer we just had to to build the
generator basically which isn't that
hard
um i think what we struggled uh with a
bit was basically finding a baseline to
compare with this is why we built this
this numerical task because this is such
a
novel kind of path in symbolic
regression to look at recurrent
sequences that we didn't have
we didn't have benchmarks we didn't have
uh things to compare to and and you know
it's a bit disappointing to show some
results of in distribution accuracy if
you have nothing to compare to so yeah
yeah we built this this uh new rec model
just for that purpose and um and yeah
um
in terms of yeah challenges i i i really
yeah i was i was surprised it was much
easier than i thought okay it's
interesting because i think we
interviewed we interviewed uh guillaume
and and co-authors on a previous paper
on the machine learning street talk i
asked them like pretty much i think the
same question and that they're all they
already said like no you know kind of we
plugged it in and it you know it worked
out and you know i was it was cool so i
think this is like uh maybe it's it's
forbidden knowledge but this might be
like a field of deep learning where
there's
things actually still
you you you can get you can get like
results it kind of it works maybe or
maybe let's say you get started with
something that works pretty quickly yeah
whereas whereas if you're in like
reinforcement learning you spend months
until
something actually starts working yeah
and the explanation is simple it's
basically just that you have this
synthetic task and so you have infinite
data and the big problem of deep neural
networks is when they don't have much
data then you really have to get clever
about how you regularize how you choose
your hyper parameters how you build your
architecture here you can just
throw anything at it and it'll work
it'll learn as long as it's got enough
parameters and that's one thing you have
to have a lot of compute resource for
this project and uh i mean here the
transformer is is um pretty big and it's
trained on a huge every epoch we train
has five million equations uh and and
trained you know for like uh
three weeks or something on 16 gpu so
it's you know pretty big scale thing
nice
um
lastly i just want to present this demo
you build so people can try this out for
themselves so if i input like one two
four
eight and that should probably already
be enough and then i have to like click
away
and then it will compute it will tell me
uh the next ones are 16 32 64. uh that's
pretty impressive i wanna
i think i
i try to challenge it a little bit i
like to try to to do come up with some
maybe
i i thought of like a music sequence
like
it's probably too regular
right let's see um
i think it'll get that one right
so yeah it will it will okay that that's
that is fairly regular if i look at the
plot
um but yeah i invite people to go and
challenge challenge your model a little
bit right here you can also choose uh
sequences of this uh oeas database
and um
yeah check out the model this is really
cool
all right so i think this this is there
anything you want to like special that
we haven't come to you want to mention
about the paper itself
that was that was great for me thanks
for your questions i think that was
great for me as well i i'm always happy
if i can ask like all my all my dumb
questions
to the people themselves in this case
stefan thank you very much thank you and
your co-authors for for writing the
paper and thank you so much for being
here this was really really fun thanks a
lot